foreign
excellent I'll have that then it's a bit
runny oh I like it running it's actually
very running sir no matter you may be
runnier than you'd like I don't care how
runny it is hand it over with
all speed
all right fine get him it's a federal
crime to sell overly moist Limburger
cheese
all right
[Music]
I see you cockroaches you want to play
games okay I play with you you want to
play rough okay
say hello to my little friend
it's a federal crime to sell egg
spaghetti that's less than .06 inches in
diameter
so I gave her all the cash I had and I
co-signed her car loan it's getting
serious man like she's gonna stop
dancing soon too like she's just doing
that to get through med school trust me
I believe her and um I know her
husband's still technically in the
picture but that's just because the kids
I I think it's all really going to work
out
just don't say anything okay yeah sure
whatever get him it's a federal crime to
not report a train wreck got him yeah
[Music]